if you're looking for ways to know your
worth be confident and speak things into
existence then this video is for you
here's the thing if you know what you're
worth your brand is worth then you can
get it you already said you want to play
for the Lakers right you think that's
gonna happen no I don't think that's
gonna happen I know it's gonna happen
and it's just so funny how things get to
line it up and then all of a sudden when
it happens you'd be like are you clear
boy this man need motivation watch a top
ten with belief nation what's up at
seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see explode out into the world so let's
get your motivation to attend and get
you believing in you grab a snack and
chew in today's lessons from a man who
went from studying criminal justice and
wanting to be a US Marshal to becoming
an entrepreneur with his own apparel
company big baller brand and being an
outspoken media personality he's Lavar
ball and here's my take on his top ten
rules a success enjoy
rule number one know your worth I've
told my boys this somebody got to be
better than Michael Jordan why not cheat
and just not Julian the player Jordan
the planned the big ball of bran the
triple bees this is our family brand for
our family this is what me and my wife
came up one with me and my boys together
nobody has ever had being a first-round
pick with their own brand coming out
it's gonna be lost well that's some
history changing stuff right there the
blonde brand they coke brand that's the
brand Nike made for them ain't nobody
made these triple B's for me but me and
here's a you want to go with one of
those brands but keep keep it big balls
oh this gonna be kept big baller it's
gonna be kept big baller if they don't
want to run with it there's a price for
everybody like I said the price for me
to be happy like I said you see these
three B's on the hat it's gonna cost you
one if people can laugh and be like I
don't know here's the thing if you know
what you're worth your brand is worth
then you can get it I'm not asking for a
billion dollars cuz I have to I'm asking
for a billion dollars cuz I can you ask
them for a billion hey that's where it's
at if you want to come with us
give me a billion and then ain't got to
be all you can you spent all that money
give me a hundred million for ten years
I'm good I'll make it work yeah you know
but people don't think like that but a
brand is one of the highest things you
can you can create and what I mean by
lawns will be in the first one drafted
with a brand is everybody else that gets
drafted Nike Adidas everybody scoops
them up for a couple of MIL here at the
air and they think that's something I'm
not needy like that rule number two do
what you love this is what I say the key
to life is is doing some that you love
to do
or you wanted after you have made so
much money and you have bought
everything you wanted what's left I hear
I'll have a passion but none you just
sit with a lot of money guess what now
you got some bad advice is to say you
know what I mean something to get me
over to hiding to drink out of
displaying for something to give you a
hug and say oh this is it rule number
three empower I got a life school system
here shows the boys some wall from
school and practice we make about 200
shots and shoes machines my boys make
just like there's nothing sure what's
your left see that ain't not ready for
that the next thing I do is I make him
lift weights Monday Wednesdays and
Fridays on Tuesdays and Thursdays we're
doing pull-ups so good
we just started am fine you know we
didn't want to go outside do homework we
want to stay outside keep to a lot of
people be like oh you push them to the
limit home I guide them to the limit
I'll tell them what to do and get it
done but if I gotta push you it's the
same for you but there's a fine line
between exploitation and empowering I'm
gonna tell you right now before you see
it UCLA gonna win the NCAA Championship
you think I'm playing
Pazuzu be number one because there's
only player in the track that can make
everybody else
probably stuffed over to me do you feel
that with some of the comments you have
made do you think that the competition
going is different for your kids because
like Oh your daddy said you better than
me
hey buddy tomba oh you can have an X on
this back and they gonna come order how
do you think he's gonna get better if
they don't come harder
I want you mad as hell at myself when
you've seen you like imma tear his ass
up cuz you know what are you thinking
just what I'm here for
you're not gonna give me nothing but I'm
gonna make you a believer rule number
four speak things into existence
I said speak it I think when you calm
you what do you mean by that if I keep
talking about it may after a while I
start I'll tell you something about my
wife when I met her I never knew her
name I seen her walking down the hallway
and I told her what I'd even ask an
excuse me what's your name I said girl I
don't know what me and you gonna do but
we're gonna do something together I
transferred in from Washington State
came to Cal State
oh yeah I gotta go holla but here's the
thing I plan to see you gonna think
about it whether it be positive or
negative you still thinking about it so
I keep saying are you gonna be a Laker I
see will be a Laker Winnie's little man
you wanna take magic spike man and it's
just so funny how things get to line it
up and then all of a sudden when it
happens you'd be like are you clear boy
talking to existence man cuz I this is
what I feel that whatever you want to do
whatever you want to do I think you can
you can do it just like Nike say just do
it and underarmor protect his house for
big baller brand our word is built for
this are you built for this you can go
so far then it starts getting hard and
it's easy to say you know what I don't
wanna do this man
rule number five don't please everybody
so when people throw a hey tej what's
the proper response for
somebody listening the proper response
for somebody listen well they don't stop
you should do what you do yeah don't
worry about what if they have behaviors
anytime you're in a limelight you gonna
have fifty percent of people like you a
50 percent adult you're not gonna please
everybody yeah you're not gonna have
everybody hate you because some people
won't be like you know what I'm like
what are you doing I like what they're
doing but you're not going to please
everybody but if you get stuck on having
haters be like oh man I don't like that
guy nobody doing nothing bad and have no
bad vices you fine don't hurt nobody to
do whatever spoken keep going forward
rule number six
be confident the last year has been the
story of the ball family like you are
everywhere up everywhere cuz people like
that controversial stuff and it's just
like this you had a good guys we got the
bad guys so it's a good guy but
negativity sales so everybody won't jump
on me but that's fine
why they jumping on me have fun cuz my
son is whooping your ass on that quick
are you cool with that yeah I'm fine
with it I do all my plate on the court
so don't be one off of it one of the
teams that you might get drafted by the
ping-pong balls fall the right way as
the Lakers
you already said you want to play for
the Lakers right you think that's gonna
happen no I don't think that's gonna
happen
I know it's don't happen alecko's don't
get that ball didn't go get that ball do
you ever think about like your dad is so
confident in these visions and these
dreams that he has that like but you're
the one who has to carry them out he
backed like that for 19 years so it's
nothing new to me I wouldn't be here
without him so if I'll go back on him
that's like going back home what I've
been doing my whole life I don't think
that's right if you don't want all this
attention don't be good guess what ain't
nobody gonna show them nothing everybody
is saying how come Longo is not like his
father he better not be like me raised
in Chino Hills I'm raising south-central
he is we is also won't do him i'ma do me
rule number seven create your own path
so originally you thought you would go
ahead and make your deal the way most
kids coming up do with Nike Under Armour
Reba here's the thing right from day one
I kind of wanted them to say no
so I could do I just wanted to make sure
they said you got one I got told my boys
we're gonna have our almost shoes when
they were little say think about y'all
told them that we yes oh shoot we don't
have to go this route right here
everybody been going a certain way it's
just like what the AE you are getting
everything but if you want to do things
your way it's just like you you break
away into Yongsan you you're the man
that's true but you probably started off
working behind some people in use like
man I figure I got more value to this
rule number eight shoot for the top
well the X's on the back here's the
thing coming from South Central this is
the X on your back when you don't have
that guy's money or you didn't beat up
his brother um and they put an X on you
in them streets X on my son's back on
the basketball court boy you know but
anything worth taking and you want to be
good they coming after you you don't
think you're gonna slide it in B and
they don't want none just like they said
oh so you lost the ball one the far been
talking about I want to basketball ain't
one-on-one it's five on five and why are
you doing that Alonso wouldn't be
thinking is it so you're the one they
call Westbrook one they call upon dude
if you want to be the best play in a
world you got to go after those guys
rule number nine be true to yourself
what's your philosophy that's made you
stand out from the crowd my philosophy
that make me stand out for the crowd as
I do it my way I trusted believe you the
way I'm doing it and I'm just doing me
so it ain't no big deal about it
whatever you do you gotta suffer
consequences whether it be good or bad
but do you you told you if you are a
killer amazing don't try to be when you
get caught be soft man if you gonna be
truly Elsa be truly yourself whatever
you do and suffer the consequences some
look at some of it but to be true to
yourself and rule number ten always
speak your mind what made you say that
one day Lonzo is going to be better than
a Steph Curry Golden State hey let me
tell you this right now I have the
utmost confidence of what my boy is
doing I'm gonna tell you right now
get better than Steph Curry to me yeah
put Steph Curry on UCLA team right now
and put my boy on the all the state
watch what happened let's go back to
your Steph Curry my son's gonna be
better than Steph right if you could do
it again what you pull it back and say
no and here's the thing I don't pull
anything back whatever I say I say it's
just like with Charles Barkley is saying
with all these guys if Charles thought
like me maybe he'd win a championship
that hurt
cuz he's saying sometimes when stuff
come out of people's mouths is just
stupid
guess what you talking to so everybody
has an opinion how things work I don't I
don't care about that I put the the
goals up high just like I understand
that my son is but I know what my boys
about I know what work you put in it's
not a one-on-one sport but if it is
one-on-one I'm gonna take the taller
faster stronger guy so I really like his
confidence in his bravado I think people
need more of that you don't need to be
super controversial you don't need to
get in people's faces but I think
believing in yourself more is important
I think a lot of people have insane
talent and abilities and they don't have
enough self-confidence to go off and
chase their dream to believe that they
could be the best to get that big client
to launch that big brain I don't think
people believe themselves enough to be
able to do it and so I really respect
that about him in terms of the rules I
think number four is gonna be my
personal favorite speak things into
existence and why I like that is it's
not just speaking things into existence
when you're talking to other people it's
also for yourself I find that a lot of
the new ideas I come up with at first
it's just an idea it's just a seed and I
might explain it to somebody and in that
first explanation this is super
important in that first explanation it
doesn't always come off as a
fully-fledged idea it's just a seed it's
just something that might happen and
then every
I explained it a little bit more it
becomes a little bit more fully formed
it becomes a little bit more rial ittle
bit more tangible and the more I talk
about it the more it becomes into
existence not just to the people around
me but for myself the more I believe in
it more the more I fully rounded out
that idea a little bit more as well and
so I think it's really really important
that start speaking out your goals speak
out what you want to build and it's
gonna sound crazy and over-the-top and
too bold at some points but the more you
speak it out the more comfortable you
get and be able to speak it out the more
confident you get in it and then the
more likely it's actually going to
happen because you start to believe in
it a little bit more so rule number four
is my personal favorite I left enough
from you guys what was your favorite
where's your number for the herbs are
you one with me team rule number four or
was the one that you like better let me
know leave it down in the comments below
now I made this video because Rico love
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next check out the link in the
description you can go to the request
line and cast your vote I also want to
give a quick shout-out to xenos a No
thank you so much for winning one of our
comments of the day with your awesome
comments and then when you got the
package in the mail you posted it to
Twitter I really appreciate all your
support men all the love all the
contribution you've given and thank you
for sharing it on Twitter as well so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope we continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love
I'll see you soon
we did three tournaments so far in AU
the first tournament we went one in
three and Melo average like 50 points
does the second one you know we went to
and two and I told him I said them the
more games we play the more we lose them
because you're tired because you're not
going into the game with a game plan
when you're gonna be aggressive in the
beginning and then start passing or
start pass and then be aggressive you've
got to learn that from Lonzo knowing
when they pick your choices but you
gotta trust your teammates you're gonna
get tired if you've got a guy running
down and sprint down throwing the ball
you don't have to make every bucket so
then the last tournament we just did
people were shot because we went for
Ando and Melo I had a couple of games
where we were down with two minutes left
we're down by 11 and he makes a buzzer
beater for us to win so he does whatever
it takes to win another game he's
setting up before he's playing now
seeing what's going on
oh he's not getting back quick so I can
throw it along with and always like are
they getting back now that leaves me
open for a wide open three pointer so is
learning how to win because I was trying
to explain to them it's not about you no
more where you used to be mellow and you
got your two brothers follow yeah so now
if you got to do that also make
everybody better and make people have
confidence in you I said if you want to
look at a person who's really really
good its Westbrook but he can't win all
those games you're gonna burn out until
you learn you can't throw the ball to
the guy and expect him every time I get
out better make it you got thought at
one time at the time I was hoping and
taking the rice out we could but if you
don't get that confidence in your team
you're just gonna wear yourself out but
you're gonna play very hard cuz
everywhere he goes he goes to the top he
has like like like the high school for
years finally got a state title
I told him whenever you go to UCLA
you've got to have championship pedigree
so if you don't want to stay title
you're just another good player so they
don't even have confidence and you win
in the championship because you don't
have championship pedigree
now it took me four years to do that
imagine if you stayed four years or UCLA
see but I don't want to be known as the
best college player no I wanted to be
known as the best player ever so you got
to go to that next level as quick as
possible and start working on here's my
thing
you always got something improved you
want to be the best so you don't stop
going until you the best between you tap
out like Kobe Bryant we waited 20 years
to see if he can pass Jordan he could
but it was a heck of a ride watching him
mm-hmm so you've got a go for that and I
think LeBron you know probably had to
prove nothing to us but I think you must
prove to yourself and that's how my boy
rolls he don't worry about proving
everything everybody else he has to
prove it to himself so he has to give
110% to be the best ever I didn't tell
him they see if you can get as good as
Jordan or as good as LeBron
I want my son's to be the best ever the
most important work ever if you have to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple that would
be like a little beacon they believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]